this is game eight of the 2021 fide
world chess championship and as robert
just said this was another petrov a uh a
choice from the world champion predicted
on the board by five in a car wanna here
in the studio as not just a pet shop but
the exact line with bishop b3 and d5 and
knight takes e5 now here when young
played knight d7 this is when we had our
first not necessarily surprise right you
highlighted the main line including the
uh the game between bishi and non and
wong hao from the 2019 fiji grand swiss
uh that occurs with knight to c3 but
instead fabi we had knight takes d7 and
then the actual first surprise this
interesting move knight d2
yeah this is a rare move and we pointed
out the reason for it is because if
white castles first
and after bishop d6 knight to d2
uh if magnus were to try the same
approach black is not forced to take on
d2 transposing into the game but can
castle using the tactic
available to him which is bishop takes
h2 if white captures on e4
and here black would equalize very
easily yep
because regaining the piece and
and uh staying equal material with the
with an equal position so magnus had a
tricky little idea to sleeve it's again
typical magnus to
have some small try which
uh you know on paper it looks like black
equalizes comfortably but he understands
that there's some
small problems to solve and as robert
mentioned
he's in a good posit he was in a good
position in the match up uh one game
so he could afford to play a slightly
more
quiet and solid line taking no risks
because we understood why it risks
nothing in this type of position but
still keeping some slight pressure on
young and in this position here after
castles we you've mentioned no real risk
but some slight pressure there were so
many lines we were looking at that
really showed how how tricky this
position is for black ultimately yawn
actually took a lot of time here before
the movie on cork but remind us robert
of just the critical reasons why simple
moves like castles could have been hard
for black yeah this is a game is a great
demonstration of first move advantage
yeah because after castling we have the
same exact position for both sides but
white gets to strike first with queen to
h5 threatening queen takes h7 checkmate
threatening queen takes d5 and if black
is forced to play f5 you have made a
huge concession the e5 square
potentially the e6 square and the e file
white is first to to that because the
rooks are connected so that's why jan
decided not to play castles kingside
played the adventurous h5 but it was the
follow-up after this that really caught
us off guard yeah magnus in turn spent a
lot of time thinking here which was
interesting right because magnus uncorks
knight d2 yawn takes a whole lot of time
to play h5 magnus really stops to think
i think in hindsight we can say it was
because he might have already been
sensing okay
this is an opportunity here right i'm
gonna get something dynamic enough to
push for and he plays not the obvious
rookie one check which may have maybe
has a little something not even a more
logical move like queen f3 that we were
looking at but a move we hadn't really
talked about except for really briefly
this move queen e1 check was played
to ask the question to the king but also
to create this interesting threat of
transitioning into a position where the
dark square bishops come off the board
in a huge way for white
yeah h5 was a fascinating move
i i feel like it was the result of
knowledge of the position i think that
yon knew something about this line yeah
and because
in hindsight we know that h5 would have
worked out quite fine for black but
after queen to e1 which uh i'm sure was
a surprise for eon and a surprise for
all of us
queen to e7 i think would have been a
fairly equal past uh fairly easy pass
path to equality and we were looking at
the line where black's king runs up to
f6 queen takes e7 king takes e7 rook at
e1 king to f6
the king is momentarily in some danger
after h4 but then black would play
bishop to f5 trading off more pieces
including the bishop which is slightly
worse than whites and leading to i think
a pretty much dead equal position yeah
if janet played queen 7 i don't think he
would have encountered very serious
problems
um that's not to say that he would have
necessarily held the game
after that
he might still have been put under
pressure later
but i don't think that he would have
faced opening problems well perhaps even
more illogical though was that not just
that he played king f8 that that move
may be okay but after bishop before he
then played queen e7 right so if you
were going to do it why not do it before
it's the question that i think everyone
wants the answer to it didn't really
make sense and his position wasn't that
bad even after this point we saw that
bishops get traded but the issue is that
rook on h8 you can lift up to h6 an idea
that we're talking about during the game
and eventually happen but the problem is
you can never quite bring his rook to e6
or the h5 pawn once pawns advance they
can't move back and when your king is on
that side of the board if you lose that
kind of pawn your king's in really big
danger so the move h5 had its purposes
but now that rook couldn't quite get
into the game yeah and queen g5 was the
move that really highlights what you
said that the rook would love to come
over here and challenge the e file but
not so fast because of the pawn the
queen would love to come over and get
this thorn out of his shoes so to speak
but you got to worry about d5 and
because of that yawn played c6 but now
robert you highlighted a really critical
point which is that because this pawn
comes to c6 to defend d5 the bishop
actually suddenly has less scope and
that led to some forcing lines for
magnus he played rook takes e8 maybe
there were other options but immediately
grabbing the e-file and trying to get
aggressive over here because of the the
lack of activity that that bishop now
had right because rookie six would be
available yep and if we just go through
that line once more rook takes e6 you
can't take with the pawn but then you
have a terrible structure yeah the queen
on g5 is great black's pawns can't move
so you take with the queen you lose h5
you get a single check on e1 and
unfortunately in chess you can't play
bishop to b5 you can't jump over your
own pawn here otherwise black would be
winning but because that pawn went to c6
magnus realized he could capitalize on
the moment and take over the e-file yeah
and that's exactly the kind of moment
that just is whatever you want to call
it magnus carlson's calling card the
little things right that become big
things he's king of making the mountains
out of molehills if you will pawn on c6
led to this forcing line where black
problems were becoming even more clear
queen of six is now played because the
pawn does defend d5 but after queen to
e3 and bishop d7 you said again magnus
knows when to change the position and he
did so here and jan in hindsight
we know the next move was a big mistake
should he have also tried to maintain
this tension you feel like that was
right on cue in terms of what black has
to play
i think that uh the move h3 is a bit
underappreciated because this was
actually one of the most impressive
moves in the game i thought yeah it
looks like white needs to do something
very direct but in fact i liked uh h3
just giving white's king some luft and
we saw a line after h3 black plays queen
to d6 trying to trade rooks by e6 queen
to g5
queen to f6 trying to trade queens again
queen to g3 queen d6 trying to trade
queens
for the third time
now if y plays rookie 5
black no longer has rookie 6 as an
option if the poem were on h2 black
would have rookie 6 with a good position
but here rook takes h5 as this would be
met by this with a pawn on h2 yeah now
white's king has that square on h2 to go
to white's bishop is not forced into
passivity so it stays on d3 and white
has a healthy extra pawn so this was the
point of h3 the reason why
yon couldn't immediately solve his
issues and why he played a waiting move
in return h4 which is a perfectly good
move
but now magnus
could say well my h3 pawn is more useful
than your h4 pawn because i never have
to worry about the back rank again
and then he hit in the center with c4 he
sensed this was the moment to try to
play concretely although this move
likely doesn't lead to an advantage
uh
it still gives black concrete problems
to solve and for some reason
jan wasn't ready to start calculating
lines
yep he correctly took
maybe maybe uh taking wasn't necessary
but we felt like taking on c4 was the
correct decision for black
and it was at this moment
that yon chose a shocking move
b5
the move that will be talked a lot about
again because it
what are all the reasons well obviously
objectively it's not a good move right
it lost the pawn
but it also arguably was not necessary
yet you had been holding well robert for
some time right and because of the
nature in which it leads to forcing
lines you have to assume okay if you're
if you're forcing something you better
have calculated but when you when you
clearly didn't it can only be described
as a reckless move something that sergey
karjakin did so well in his world
championship match against magnus is he
didn't force the issue he was okay to be
the one reacting to max's plans even
though it meant he would not get
activity of his own he said i'm solid
enough i'll be able to hold b5 is going
full steam ahead and the position
doesn't call for it now your pawn on a7
was directly lost and what my coach said
growing up his mistakes often come in
pairs in chess and it was first b5 then
after queen a3 check king the g8 queen
queen d8 doesn't even put up a fight
because the only resistance that could
be had in the position was bishop takes
h3 it's going to be a bad end game
you're going to grovel for a draw and
maybe you won't make it but queen d8 is
just saying i have no fight left in me
this is your game and for those who may
be just tuning in perhaps the line there
were many that might have
might have been on the board in the game
could have been something like this
where black does have bishop five and
while again objectively white is up a
pawn and we did display in real time
probably probably some of the better
plans for white perhaps starting with
moves like rookie five to try to convert
at the very least this needs to be
converted this is going to take some
work and black's drawing chances are are
clear only being down a pawn
but in the game as robert said perhaps
even more perplexing than b5 was the
follow-up queen d8 and now you're just
you're just sitting in a position down a
pawn right here white has the pawn and
the compensation so to speak bishop b3
rook up to e4
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go forward i
don't know that there was anything
better for yon at this point the
pressure on f7 via the x-ray vision that
the queen displays on the seventh rank
forces a move like bishop e6 well let's
just show why why young didn't make a
waiting move like g6 okay
in fact there's probably more than one
reason rook to f4 is probably winning on
the spot there's also rook takes h4 if
we like
cute little tactics we we love cute
little tactics around here queen takes
h4 queen to b8
y has picked up another pawn and the
rook is coming with it yep uh
so jan was obligated to trade bishops
and although he wants to trade bishops
he doesn't want to trade bishops in this
way where he further damages his
structure right
and after in this position we already
saw the writing on the wall it's not
only that white is up a pawn it's that
black has too many weaknesses to hold
if he could
try to defend everything while creating
counterplay against white's king maybe
there would be some drawing chances but
he tried to create counterplay with
queen a5 but he wasn't able to hold all
his weaknesses yeah
goes for some checks but magnus now at
this point was in
he was in uh
whatever you want to call it
conversion mode right he had the focus
of uh
of a predator and he never let up from
here on out
and uh i can go through these games the
centralized queen is obviously super
instructive as a very important thing
for everyone to take away that's how you
convert these end games the queen does
the job of protecting against perpetuals
as well as helping the pawns go forward
um and really robert you were just you
were just applauding magnus's just
discipline here right leading by example
if you will is what the world champion
did he never he made this look so easy
yeah and he actually also changed his
plans because sometimes we're stubborn
as human beings but also as chess
players where we come up with a plan in
the next few moves he brought his queen
to c3 when i was saying he could go
queen d1 he goes queen c3
and then we see a couple moves played
with check the king comes back he goes
back to d3 and guess what he goes back
to d1 and it's important that you're
willing to go back to a plan you could
have played and realized that maybe this
is what i should have done and all the
moves for the most part would have been
winning but he made this as easy as
possible on himself so he took his time
he kept his composure and then he was
saying i'm willing to change my mind and
go for a plan that may objectively be
best so i think it was a great
demonstration of of how to play these
games especially if you're a newer chess
player you can think when you have an
hour on your clock and if you're winning
there's no need to rush
well said and perhaps the last good
example he set is that against any
tenacious defender at some point they
will challenge you with a plan that at
least
looks crazy even if it isn't as as
complicated as first seems and he still
kept his focus taking with the h pawn
allowing the wild looking h3
again note that taking with the queen to
keep your excuse me taking with the
queen to keep your king side looking
pretty could actually be a huge blunder
due to ideas like queen e1 check and
queen e5 so really good good example
again you have to calculate in the end
because a good defender will make you do
so and he did just that with queen f3
you realize it was all just smoke and
mirrors despite how scary this kind of
looks and yawn in fact resigned
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 feed a
world championship is brought to you by
our partners at coinbase whether you're
just thinking about making your first
crypto purchase just wanting to learn a
little bit more about the crypto
industry or if you've been doing this
thing for years and you're an
experienced trader coinbase is the place
to be
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin just for signing
up and verifying your account today we
really encourage you to do so go check
them out at coinbase.com
[Music]
you